I kind of want everybody to like loosen
up so if everybody wants to get up we're
gonna do a little dance
come on you go like starving it's gonna
be you let's celebrate
I kinda want to just give a big round of
applause to the organizers for doing an
incredible job where you to like lift me
or something can we give a big round of
applause to the organizers
[Applause]
oh my god good turn oh okay thank you so
much for dancing I'm so honored to get
to close out those last year's coughing
it's so bittersweet that this is the
last time that this is all going to be
put together but I'm sure that we'll all
get together again soon my name is
Patricia and I've had many many past
lives but for now I'm a front-end
developer and when I began teaching
myself JavaScript and when I got
involved in the JavaScript community I
finally joined our beloved trash fire
that is Twitter and the thing that I
noticed that was the most peculiar to me
was that there was this perennial debate
that kept happening about whether or not
a hot dog was a sandwich and at first I
was like is this just like in my
microcosm of friends is this just
something that I happen to be seeing
because of like confirmation bias or is
like and I was like no no because
Silicon Valley just recently did a joke
about it on their show they made an app
called not hot dog where you could take
a picture of something and it would tell
you if it was a hot dog or if it was not
a hot dog and so in the show they take a
bunch of pictures of sandwiches and
they're like oh not a hot dog but then
they take a picture of up talking
they're like yep that's a hot dog so I
started asking my friends what was going
on why was this debate happening why was
this such a hot topic and that they told
me that the reason why it was because of
ontology and I was like like metaphysics
like is this some kind of matrix meme
that I'm not in on like what I don't for
me ontology is like the study of the
nature of being and reality so I was
very confused they were like no no no no
no this is ontology which is in
information science which is the formal
naming and definition of types
properties and interrelationships of
entities in a domain of discourse so
basically it's just
fancy way of saying categorizing [ __ ]
and so we use ontology and computer
science to limit complexity and organize
information but for me it was so forced
for me I saw hot dog and like I was it
made my blood boil to hear this argument
over and over and over again because I
felt like they were trying to stick a
round peg through a square hole and I
was like you guys they're not or
everybody they're not hot dogs like hot
dogs are not sandwiches hot dogs are
most like tacos like why can't you stop
talk like why are you still talking
about sandwiches because it really
bothered me because what it demonstrated
to me was the way that all of our
unconscious bias is used and manipulates
even our own minds when we don't realize
it to reinforce existing stereotypes and
reinforce existing unconscious bias and
existing systems of oppression like the
sandwich was invented by Earl of
Sandwich in the 1750s he put a PC asses
his servant hate sees like those anyways
he asked his servant to give him his
meals between two pieces of bread and
what happened was he would order that
from the gambling table and his friends
were like I'll have what sandwiches
having like I just read that in
quotations and I would really like to
know if that was what actually happened
or not but because then the When Harry
Met Sally scene has a whole different
meaning but so basically like I with the
help of my friend Justin we like made
this meme to stop this debate because we
were just so tired of hearing it
and Justin filled me in on this really
great book which is called surface in
essence by Douglas Hofstadter and
Emmanuel Sanders and it's all about how
analogies are the fuel and fire of
thinking and category they say
categorization is the pulsing pulsating
heartbeat of thought allowing us to
exploit the rich storehouse of wisdom
in our past and categorization gives us
the feeling of understanding a situation
you're in by providing a clear
perspective on it
allowing hidden items and qualities to
be detected future events to be
anticipated and the consequences of
actions to be foreseen so by considering
how we think we can get to the root of
unconscious bias which is stereotypes we
have to look at these broad
generalizations that we use and are
reinforcing unconscious bias and systems
of oppression through analogies and
metaphors that we use every day to be
more inclusive we have to consider how
these analogies are manipulating us and
these are the three most common ways
that analogies can be used to manipulate
first they can be invisible so anything
like like just seeing the word like any
language that you use has an invisible
analogies in it a dictionary is nothing
but invisible analogies like how can you
define a word without other words you
need analogies to do that also the
second most common ways that analogies
manipulate us is that they are
inaccurate or that they lack nuance and
the last way is propaganda and the
reason why I divided it into these three
groups is because the first one involves
no intent there is no intent on the side
of the person who is using the analogy
or the metaphor to manipulate the intent
is not there and therefore it should it
would be invisible because it can't be
detected the second example inaccurate
or lacking nuance is an example of when
an analogy or metaphor is manipulating
us because of a negligence so like with
the hot dog and sandwich debate there is
a negligence on the part of the people
who were arguing that hot dogs were like
sandwiches to really consider whether or
not those categories were being fed to
them by all of their past knowledge or
whether they were actually going out of
their way to figure out what was the
best way to categorize a hot dog and the
last way is obviously propaganda
obviously has it intent its
these analogies are meant to manipulate
us and execute the agenda of the author
so we're mostly going to be focusing on
inaccuracy lack of nuance and
invisibility and because metaphors are
dangerous metaphors are not to be
trifled with a single metaphor can give
birth to love this is one of my favorite
quotations from The Unbearable Lightness
of being by Milan Kundera we need two
metaphors are the stuff of life and we
need to be careful and question then in
order to bridge the gap between us and
the others the others that we don't
understand that we don't know how to
connect with Claude Steele is the author
of a book called whistling Vivaldi he's
a social psychologist and researcher at
Columbia University and he wrote this
book whistling Vivaldi about his
research into stereotypes and how they
manipulate us and how we can break them
down and whether or not they actually
have an effect on us and after many many
experiments that were redone by many
many other social psychologists behind
him he used a kind of language that I
really appreciated because I felt like
it got to the crux of the issue and the
reason why we have so much difficulty
bridging this gap and tearing down our
unconscious bias and that's that he
inverted the conversation for me so
instead of talking about privilege and
instead of talking about all of the ways
that we benefit which like privilege is
not bad privilege is not inherently bad
when we talk about privilege we're
talking about the things that you that
you get that make your life easier we're
not talking about how you're costing
someone else something it however that
does enter into the equation and that is
why I think that there's so much
difficulty understanding these concepts
and so I'd like you to take a moment and
invert these concepts in your thought
and instead of thinking about privilege
when you think about the inequalities in
the world think about stereotype threat
which is what underrepresented
minorities experience it's a combination
of stigma pressure and identity
contingencies identity contingencies
exist for everyone when a white sis mail
signs up for a class on african-american
history
he has an identity contingency that is
going to create stigma pressure and
therefore will have a stereotype threat
in that class so by inverting this I
sorry excuse me I lost my voice on the
plane so by inverting this and
considering stereotype threat we can see
the conversation from the other point of
view so instead of subjugating us to
instead of talking about the things that
you have to deal with when you're in a
situation because you have a given
social identity we should consider the
circumstances you have to deal with
because as it underrepresented minority
I'm always aware of what other people
could think I'm always living in two
different worlds and we should put the
dancing in here at this time it's really
hard to talk for 35 minutes straight
when you're losing your voice take a
loss in real quick steel talks about in
whistling Vivaldi oh my god am I ever
gonna be able to finish this sentence
um the work of Edward Jones and Richard
Nesbitt and how they exploit explain how
these different things manifest in the
world and they explained it by talking
about observers perspective and actors
perspective which is that so they talk
about observers perspective and actors
perspective and how observers emphasize
what they can see and they D emphasize
things that they can't see they D
emphasise how the systems of oppression
that are not obvious to them and as an
underrepresented minority and the actors
perspective these are things that were
hyper aware of these are things that
influence every single decision that we
make for example people talk a lot about
male chivalry but there's also female
chivalry which is this concept of like
women being performative doing our hair
being subversive you know putting on
nice outfits like that is female
chivalry that is the actors perspective
side of the equation that people don't
see and when we can't see inequalities
they manifest more quickly and they
manifest the social socio-economic
disadvantage segregated social practices
and research of cultural orientations
the other side of actors perspective is
very perfectly described here by W EB
Dubois in the soul of black folk which
was published in 1903 and I highly
recommend that everyone take a minute to
read it but basically WB Dubois created
this concept of double consciousness
which is that as an underrepresented
minority you're always aware of the
multiple worlds that you exist in you
exist in your own world of your own
identities and that can be multifaceted
depending on your sexual orientation
your gender if you are ill or not and
this causes cognitive dissonance it
makes it more difficult to operate in
the world so and this leads me to like
something else
that is really important to me this is
something that happens on teams very
often which is Ringelmann effect which
is where as the group grows individual
productivity drops and the reason why
this this affects URM is the most is
because privilege works as social
capital and it allows people to do what
is called social loafing
so you see here TJ Miller is just
enjoying a head off of a bong while
everybody else is working around him
right that's social loafing and what
happens is underrepresented minorities
pick up the slack so to reduce this from
happening to keep this from happening
you have to limit your scope of your
projects you have to keep your groups
small you have to divvy up
responsibilities equitably and you have
to reward coordination and cooperation
and because people like getting credit
you're gonna have a happier team a more
psychologically safe team at a better
community is my lipstick okay so
Ringelmann effect is one thing that can
happen another thing that can happen is
called bystander effect bystander effect
was researched by John Darley and
bible-- atany in 1968 after the death of
kitty Genovese a in 1964 at 3:00 a.m.
she was attacked over the course of an
entire the entire rest of the evening
and morning and the New York Times
published that 37 people witnessed her
attack but in reality it was more like
about a dozen people but imagine that
you are out in the middle of the street
and someone attacks you and 12 people
walk past and don't do anything about it
and so this really inspired these two
social researchers to look into why this
was happening they did a number of
different experiments one of my
favorites was the smoke room experiment
where they put a person in a room with a
questionnaire and then they released
smoke into the room and they tested to
see how long it took before they
reported that there was smoke coming
into the room and as the group increased
as more people were in the room filling
out the survey the length of time that
it took to report what was happening
what up dramatically
and that's because of diffusion of
responsibility so what they noted was
they with bystander of fact what happens
is you notice interpret assess degree of
responsibility form assistance and
implement an action choice and that
action choice can be direct intervention
detour intervention or no intervention
and biased prevents people from directly
helping those that need help from
directly to helping people that
absolutely could be advantaged by the
privilege that you can offer so they
Darley and let found that responsibility
depends on whether or not we feel that
the person who needs help
deserves it our competence and our
relationship to them and detour response
detour intervention doesn't work in
situations of bias because the systems
of oppression that already exist don't
allow for help so how do we do effective
direct intervention how do we help the
people who need to be helped in the
1970s in New York crime was really high
in the subways it was practically unsafe
to go on the subway but this
organization called the guardian angels
came together and it was their
membership was mostly young men black
and Latino who had a skewed gang life in
their own neighborhoods to better their
city they had this system that I loved
it was fantastic what they did was they
put one person on each subway car and if
a fight broke out or if someone got
attacked on a subway car they would know
because at every subway stop they all
poked their heads out the subway door
and check to make sure that everyone was
visible and if someone wasn't visible
they would know that the person in that
subway car needed assistance and they
would all run to that subway car to help
they did this despite the fact that the
police was we're calling them vigilantes
despite the fact that they were at first
shunned by many and over time because
they helped so many people the attitude
of the public turned around in a few
years the public was able to go on the
subway safely they were able to enjoy
they're City again and it is because of
the guardian angels that the subway got
cleaned up in the 80s another example of
direct intervention that worked despite
a system of oppression not helping is
something that was described on reply
all's writing on the wall episode at
Colgate University in upstate New York
the Black Student Union leaders were
getting direct death threats through the
anonymous messaging app Yik yak and the
administration of the school refused to
do anything about it they refused to
contact yak and ask them about the
people who were posting these death
threats they refused to do any
punishment when they found out who these
people were and so what happened was
assistant professor of biology Jeff
Holmes started this campaign that he
called the Yik yak take-back and it was
a social media campaign akin to sending
Ned Flanders to comment on 4chan the
rules were that professors needed to go
on and all they had to do was sign their
name but what they and he encouraged
them to post messages of well-wishes
messages about joking about how hard the
midterm was gonna be broadcasting
congratulations to students on their
final fun finishing their thesis and
what he did was by witnessing by using
his privilege he witnessed these death
threats and it created this environment
where it was no longer a place where it
was acceptable to post these kinds of
messages because the professor's got
involved and they directly intervened we
have to get directly involved to make
change and we have to recognize when an
underrepresented minority points out bad
behavior we are challenging you to be
better if we felt that your intent was
malicious or bad in any way shape or
form I promise you
underrepresented minorities are going to
disengage they're going to block you on
social media they're not going to risk
their own safety to tell you that they
think that you were wrong when we feel
that we're in danger we
you know to tendin to be friend we know
to go to our groups because the group is
more likely to survive harassment than
an individual but when we see bad
behavior and we trust that the person
has good intentions we're going to call
it out and when it gets called out it's
best if you listen internalize apologize
be accountable for your actions and be
attentive to the ways that that was part
of your unconscious bias so that you can
take it out of your unconscious bias so
that you can be conscious of those
moments because we care too much to stop
demanding more this is a matter of our
safety this isn't a matter of our what
we'd like to do and what we don't like
to do I don't like having to confront my
friends when they say something
inappropriate I don't like having to
confront people on Twitter about a
comment or a word that was used that was
a ballista
it's what we need to do in order to make
a better society each choice is an
opportunity to influence the world that
we exist in Sartre when he wrote on
Being and Nothingness
wrote notes about creating an ethical
model to pair with his existential
philosophy but he never got beyond notes
Simone de Beauvoir did she wrote ethics
of ambiguity which perfectly
encapsulates its I looked for years for
an ethical model that I felt matched
what I was internally feeling because I
know that there's nothing new Under the
Sun and someone must have written it and
what's fascinating to me is that her
book isn't even mentioned on Wikipedia's
page for existentialism it's a direct
response to on being in nothingness it's
not mentioned in most philosophy
curriculums but she wrote about how
because we have freedom Eden and because
of existentialism because of the fact
that likes Archer killed God and
basically said that it's our choices are
our own it means that we have our own
responsibility to make our own choices
in each and every moment in order to
help not just ourselves but the society
that we choose to participate in
participating in society social contract
is a choice
and therefore because social contract is
a choice it is imperative that a moral
attitude be adopted as well so after
discussing all of this high-end like
social theory let's look at another
example or unconscious bias exist so
here's an analogy that's so pervasive
that we usually wouldn't think blink
tight twice but you might not have known
this but actually before the compass was
invented East used to be at the top of
the map because the Sun would rise in
the east and so maps were oriented with
East at the top but when you see this
analogy that west to east is equal to
left-to-right your mind doesn't think
about it it's an invisible analogy and
how does like how does this apply to us
as developers why man honestly the West
Wing does a much better job of
explaining this than I do so partly to
aggressively support legislation that
would make it mandatory for every public
school in America to teach geography
using the Peters projection map instead
of the traditional Mercator give me 200
bucks and it's done really
No why are we changing maps because CJ
the Mercator projection has fostered
European imperialist attitudes for
centuries and created an ethnic bias
against a third world really the german
cartographer Mercator originally
designed this map in 1569 as a
navigational tool for European sailors
the map enlarges areas at the poles to
create straight lines of constant
bearing or geographic direction so it
makes it easier to cross an ocean but
yes it distorts the relative size of
nations and continents are you saying
the map is wrong oh dear yes now look at
Greenland okay now look at Africa
okay you two land masses appear to be
roughly the same size yes
what a blow your mind if I told you that
Africa is in reality 14 times larger yes
here we have Europe drawn considerably
larger than South America when it's six
point nine million square miles South
America is almost double
the size of Europe's 3.8 million Alaska
appears three times as large as Mexico
when Mexico is larger by 0.1 million
square miles
Germany appears in the middle of the map
once in the northernmost quarter of the
earth-boy
relative size is one thing but you're
telling me that Germany isn't where we
think it is nothing is where you think
it is where is it I'm glad you asked it
the Peters projection
it has fidelity of access fidelity of
position east-west lines are parallel
and intersect north-south axes at right
angles what tell is that it's where
you've been living this whole time
should we continue so you're probably
wondering what all of this has to do
with social equality no I'm wondering
where France really is guys we want to
thank you very much for coming in hang
on we're gonna finish this what do maps
have to do with social equality you
asked she asked
Salvatore Anatoly of the National
Council for social studies argues in our
society we unconsciously equate size
with importance and even power I'm gonna
check in on Tommy go these guys fine
bring it in on that map he'll call me
right probably not okay
when third world countries are
misrepresented they're likely to be
valued less when we're cater maps
exaggerate the importance of Western
civilization when the top of the map is
given him northern hemisphere and the
bottom is given to the southern then
people will tend to adopt top and bottom
attitudes but wait huh world's could you
put the northern hemisphere but on the
top on the bottom how like this yeah but
you can't do that why not cuz it's
freaking me out
who doesn't love CJ Cregg so this is the
Gail Peters projection that they showed
the previous map was the Mercator
projection and Peters came up with he
described his reasoning for working on
this as because he saw that the Mercator
projection was like the cartographic
imperialism of the time however any map
that lays flat is naturally distorted
even this projection is distorted so I'm
not even going to show you what it would
look like upside down because I don't
want to freak you out any more than you
probably already are but as in politics
all identities are local and I say that
because as developers one of the things
that we work with the most is actually
Maps it's how I got started developing I
joined map time LA and worked on map
mapping projects with open street maps
and in the open street map community
they call the Google map strategy the
Starbucks test which is that they only
invest money into mapping when it's
close enough to it's a closed radius to
a chain coffee store and experts
estimate that and so like OpenStreetMaps
does this work to map in areas that are
less accessible but experts estimate the
two to five percent of OpenStreetMap
contributors are women only two to five
percent but the humanitarian
OpenStreetMap steam did a gender
equality study recently that found that
28% of remote mappers are women so
remote mappers in under service parts of
the world and when working directly with
people from communities in desperate
areas forty-eight percent were women
that's practically that's equality forty
eight percent is equality but keep in
mind that the barrier of entry for these
women is much higher these are in parts
of the world where the gender norms mean
that the women have much more work that
they have to do on top of that they're
volunteering their own personal time to
go in math in crisises in puerto rico in
tat and tasmania in africa like these
are people who they could be putting
their time towards
their own personal lives but instead
they volunteer it because mapping is
about navigating the world safely and
for women in developing countries that
safety is harder to secure and we can
make a better more inclusive internet by
working on breaking out of these
categories that we don't even see that
are around us breaking out of these
boxes and questioning the things that
the analogies and the words and the ways
that we talk about the world around us
and taking a look taking a really hard
look at ourselves and considering how
unconscious bias plays into our life
because how can we constantly talk about
our love of problem-solving which to me
is the soul of engineering and not want
to solve the interpersonal problems on
our team and in the world at large
for me it's the reason why I do this
work the reason why I do workshops on
intersectionality and inclusivity the
reason why I give talks about
unconscious bias is because as much fun
as it is to solve a bug these are the
problems that are affecting people's
lives directly and these are the issues
that really need to be solved
first and foremost so I hope that that
inspired you to take a look at your
lives and thank you so much jazz cafe'
oh thank you
you
you